[Music]  what was the bomba doing last night  during the Aubrey Plaza interview was it  a mouthpiece crazy talking to like one  of the quietest actresses in the world  and she's sitting here and I hear and  I'm like and I look over and I see him  going when he hit the tubing he was done  then suddenly out comes the earpiece who  blows in an earpiece what was that going  to accomplish  you heard me through your speakers I  don't know  I'm right here to hear down the house  man it's just quiet no no no he could  hear it too exactly you pulled the old  focus of ruining huh  yeah it gave me the old rusty trombone  Oh nicely done la Bamba  [Music]  you